living in the city can be stressful I
often find myself longing to get out
into the countryside in fact there's
plenty of evidence to suggest that this
is good for your health above and beyond
the effects of the exercise but what if
you can't get out to experience these
environments can they be brought to you
professor Bob stone is working on doing
just that and I'm going to his lab to
give it a go well we're really concerned
about the number of people who can't go
out for walks people in hospices care
homes veterans coming back from
Afghanistan and who find themselves with
amputated limbs and so on so with
virtual environments we're able to use
head mounted displays or large screens
and actually expose them to virtual
reconstructions of well-known beauty
spots not necessary in this country but
further abroad as well and how do you
actually build the world what we've done
with with these worlds because they're
geographically based is we've actually
bought the digital train data from a
geographical source and aerial
photography so we would combine those
two in the games engine software that
powers this this this this particular
environment and then we use it as a
template to populate it with man-made
objects rivers trees bushes flowers and
so on so the world that we're going to
be showing you today is based on Wembley
Bay which is a lovely piece of coastline
just east of Plymouth it's got both
fantastic coastal environment it's got
some fabulous forestry environments just
slightly inland and it is a perfect
place to go and just literally chill out
which is what I did many moons ago when
I was doing my a-level revision you
right-handed or left-handed you're
right-handed okay what we need to do is
to put these devices onto your left hand
this is the galvanic skin response meter
which if we make sure that goes right
down to the bottom of your at the base
of your fingers that will be measuring
your skin response and so we're looking
at the conductance and measuring the
trend over time and this is a pulse
oximeter which we'll be measuring
amongst other things your heart rate so
we can put it onto your index finger and
we can start that let's make sure the
thing is nice and snug in there and we
can read it of your pulse right let's
see how stressed I really am first thing
we have to do is to raise your arousal
level so that we can do some comparisons
afterwards so how good these event these
environments are we're just looking at
your mental ability to rotate in this
case the two-dimensional objects
what happens if I get one wrong give me
an electric shock no nothing is
ethically awkward is that that wouldn't
be a nice great let's have a look at
this world okay so how am I actually
going to walk around this world well
we're gonna give you this little device
which is commercially available it's
called a Zeki you move forwards and
backwards using the thumb stick you look
left and right using the thumb stick and
then if you want to look up and down
these little buttons on the front maybe
you should look down and - and to look
up so gives you complete freedom to
explore the virtual world the sound is
designed such a way that the effects are
triggered and the volume is triggered
when you approach a particular zone or
object and if I'm one of the
participants in your study what would
you actually have me do in this world
we'd ask you do two things number one is
we'd ask you to walk around for about 60
seconds take in the view and then choose
where you would like to sit or to stand
virtually so that you could actually get
the full benefit of the environment then
we do is expose you to different times
of day so for example we can have a nice
sunrise at dawn we can have a nice
sunset at dusk and we expose you to
various different environments and
various different environmental effects
we try to put in borders so that you can
for example for off the end of the
virtual world which is not very not very
restorative and presumably it's not like
a video game where you want people to be
able to run miles and miles in seconds
I think at the moment it's probably just
a little too fast we want this to be a
restorative gentle walk on the
countryside so we need to match the the
sound of the footsteps that you're
hearing which are actually important for
creating the news that you're immersed
in the world with the speed of movement
across the screen so how does this
environment make you feel it's actually
amazingly relaxing that's often the
response we get we people will sit back
and the sounds in particular they will
sit back and listen and get almost
soaked in immersed in the environment
and we always check up on how well you
really are feeling because my colleague
Chang is monitoring your heart rate and
your skin response your arousal levels
in real-time with the the laptops that
he's got in front of him as he actually
dropped it's gone down to continue okay
it's not gonna be easy taking this into
a hospital setting we have a lot of
things to consider things like ethics
things like hygiene the chances are we
will probably not be using head mounted
displays but using large screens that we
can weave into patients beds but it's
quite a challenge getting this
technology into a sterile setting such
as a hospital well we're getting a lot
of interest from non-military and and
and the medical sectors palliative care
end-of-life care vascular surgeons are
interested we're even seeing interest
for example from accident emergency Wars
could this be used to calm violent
patients who come into the wards on a
Friday or Saturday for example we hope
to get the technology into a hospices
and care homes on large screens possibly
even on portable computers like like
iPads or or Android tablets so the sky's
the limit
professor stone and his team are set to
test the virtual worlds over the next 12
months they're hoping to be treating
people in hospitals and care homes
within the next two years I thoroughly
enjoyed my stress busting walk on the
Virtual Beach maybe we should get one
for the office for nature video I'm
Daniel Cressy